so hi everyone uh we're going to start
actually 10 after but i wanted to start
with my introduction
um and also tell you about the rmk
series distinguished lecture series so
i'm shafi and the director of the
institute
and just tell you a little bit about the
rmk series it was established to
celebrate the role of um
uh dick carp the founding director of
the simon's institute
in uh establishing the field of threat
computer science setting his
foundational questions and stunning
results
and uh
in his honor this uh series features
visionary leaders in the field of threat
computer science
and is geared toward broad scientific
audience
which i think you
qualify because it's a special case
right in any case we are grateful for
the many contributions of richard carp
who
has made this series possible and i'm
delighted to uh welcome our speaker
today andrea mariarty
monteneri sorry and andre is the it's
okay for me all italians are no not
quite but
andre is the robert and barbara kleist
professor in the school of engineering
and uh professor in statistics and
mathematics at stanford
and he received his uh lara degree in
physics and phd in physics uh from pisa
in italy
and it was a postdoc at msri so he's no
foreign to berkeley and his many visits
in the institute
and
he's got many awards and distinctions
including the cnrs bronze medal for the
medical physics national science
foundation career award
james l massey award of the information
theory society
and many other things and today he's
going to talk on computational barriers
in statistical estimation and learning
so please you're welcome thank you for
coming
[Applause]
okay thanks for for the introduction and
uh yeah
so this this talk is going to be a part
of the pro program on computational
complexity and statistical inference and
what i'll try to do is try to represent
what this community is trying to achieve
to a broader scientific audience this is
the logo of the of the of the program
and this uh you know looks like a map
with some fantastic animal or magic
animals inside
and uh i think it's a nice logo because
represent a little bit the sense of
wonder in
that we we have in making these
discoveries and
and i'll try to convey to you why why
this is interesting to a broader
scientific community
okay and perhaps a good starting point
is
ask ourselves what people out there
think when they think when they hear the
word statistics since statistics is a
key word in the title and probably they
think uh
a number of important questions in
everyday life right for instance what is
the fraction of u.s population that
approves or disapproves a certain
you know policy measure
what is the fraction of patients that
will benefit for a certain medical
treatment
or finally our own favorite one given a
biased coin
we want to estimate the bias
right and
one thing that these questions have in
common is that one method or the main
method to deal with them is
is probably draw and samples uh
from any of these
phenomena and then do something with the
data
okay
so let's go with with the coins coin
tossing examples we'll throw you know
our coin that we suppose is biased
one thousand times and say that we have
473
heads and 527 tails
and let's stipulate that the bias is the
probability that you get ahead right
we estimate this by yes well most people
will or for sure most statistician would
would do this as the first thing we'll
divide the number of heads by the number
of of coins coin tosses and get 0.473
unfortunately there is always a
theoretician around that will ask you
know uncomfortable question and here the
uncomfortable question is how accurate
is this estimate
and
okay so let's try to answer the question
if you if you
you know so okay let's let's start
writing formulas
we'll write one random variable for each
of the coin tosses this takes value
zeros and one
and then our estimate is the sum of the
random variable divided by the number of
coin tosses
and now we remember that the central
limit theorem
tells us that this estimate the number
of heads the sum will be
on average n times p where p is the true
bias
and we'll have a standard deviation that
is over the square root of n
and and there will be some ball shape
some some
bell-shaped curve that describes the
distribution
so our estimate will be the true value
plus or minus an error that is of order
square root of n
okay so now we can be happy we know that
our estimate is is accurate within 1
over square root of n
but unfortunately there is always a
theoretician around that will ask us
okay fine
can you do better than this
and this is very annoying right
yeah theoreticians are in the pain
and uh but in this case we can answer
the question and the answer is no and
there is actually an information
theoretic proof of this and since i i
learned early on that every talk should
have
a proof and a joke and they better not
be the same
i'll try with the proof
okay
okay so let's assume let's we want to
try to show so this is an information
theoretic proof what does it mean
information theoretic
it it it basically means that it's the
balls in bean uh uh you know kind of
argument
okay so how do we go about it assume
that you know by by some chance we are
able to achieve accuracy much better
than some small number delta right
and now i'll draw a vertical axis this
vertical axis is the axis
with all possible values of p and i'll
stipulate that all i only consider coins
that have a bias either delta to delta 3
delta etc so these are the possible
values of the bias
and
the outcomes well of course the the
order in which the heads and the tails
come doesn't matter so the outcomes is
really the number of heads
and so i'll draw a line with the number
of possible
all the possible outcomes that are all
the integers between zero and then
okay
and then if you give me one specific
bias
one specific value of the bias i can
connect it with all the possible outcome
that are likely for that bias
and you know for instance the most
likely outcome is something like n times
p
but there is a number of possible
outcome that have no non-vanishing
probability or significant probability
and and i'll draw a little edge for each
of them
and you know again by the central limit
theorem there will be about square root
of n of these edges right
and now i can repeat the same drawing
for each possible
value of p on the left
and i get a funny looking graph like
this
okay
and now now we start counting things
what is the possible outcome here called
s the set of possible outcome well there
is at most
n plus one where n is is the number of
coin tosses
and on the other side the number of
possible values of p
is basically one over delta because you
are partitioning the interval zero one
into
into segments of l like length delta
and uh
and now we go with the with the
brilliant remark the brilliant remark is
that
if the accuracy is much less than delta
i will be able for each of this
outcome to go back right for each of the
possible outcome i should be able to
identify one only value
one unique value of the
bias so it must be true that this graph
has degree on the right
which is at most one
and now we count edges
this means that the number the number of
nodes on the on the left times the
degree
must be approximately the number
outcomes that is at most n plus one
and now we substitute one over delta
here
this is
b times square root of n about s
less than n plus one this implies that
delta is less than one over square root
of is bigger than one over square root
of n
okay so you cannot achieve accuracy this
graph cannot exist unless delta is
bigger than one over square root of n
so we actually prove the theorem
to estimate the bias of a coin with
accuracy delta
you need
at least one over delta samples and one
of our delta samples are sufficient as
our simple method showed before
okay so this is a
what we call a one-dimensional example
okay uh what i want to do next is i want
to
move to higher dimension
the phenomena that i want to talk about
happen you know mainly in high dimension
and so what does high dimension mean
high dimension means that we don't only
want to estimate one number but we want
to estimate many numbers right
so i represent this with the case in
which i want to estimate
a large number d
of coin biases
and we want to estimate them together
so
this can be a little bit confusing in
this example because you know the the
the uh kind of
coins are completely independent but
still you know estimating together might
mean that i want to estimate p in such a
way that this
norm is small so the sum of the error
achieved on all uh the coins is small
okay well these are the vector p and p
hat
okay and and
so what we do is that
okay let's let's try to think about the
same problem in this in this example
will throw n times each of the of the uh
coins and we'll have a table of numbers
of
a zero one table like this
and each column of this table is a
vector is a sample is a 0 1 vector for
instance head tail no head head tail etc
and
a natural estimator as before for for
the number of
for the bias of all the coins
is
just the empirical average of all the
coins of all these vectors so one over n
times
the sum of the x i's
and
okay now we can
go back to our information theoretic
calculation or information theory method
and try to compute what is the upper
optimal accuracy that we can achieve
here
say that we want to achieve as i said
before
uh l2 norm of p at minus p less than
delta
and if you remember before what you know
the key of the argument was to draw a
graph in the graph is on the left the
possible values of p
and on the right the possible outcome
and the possible values of p the
properties that they have to be delta
separated
so any
two of them must have at least l two
distance delta
so now this asks the question of how
many points
i can draw in the you know space of all
possible p's so the space of all
possible p is the cube
of side one in d dimension
how many points i can draw in this in
this cube
that are separated by by
uh distance at least delta
and
okay there is an easy uh kind of
volume argument that allows to guess you
that
the volume
of you know so i will divide the volume
of one of these
of the balls around one of this point
that is proportional
to delta to the d
by the volume of the ball
surrounding the cube that is
square root of d to the d
and so i get this ratio that is square
root of d over delta to the d
on the other hand the number of possible
outcomes for p
is uh
for
for a given value of the vector of bias
is square root of n to the to the d this
is the degree of the graph on the left
because well of course you have a
central limit theorem so
the counts are within square root of n
from the from the mean
and the total possible number of outcome
outcomes is n to the d
and therefore counting again edges i get
that
this number must be
less the number of edges coming up out
of the left must be less the number of
vertices on the right if i want to
reconstruct precisely exactly and
therefore delta must be at least
d over n
okay
so we proved or we we have an idea a
sketch for a theorem that one can
actually prove rigorously that is if we
want to estimate this vector p with
accuracy delta in this sense
then we need
d over delta square samples
so we need d over delta square
columns in this matrix
okay so i talked about about coins uh
for some of you this is very motivating
for other it's not as motivating but but
you know
vectors that are id
samples from a common distribution arise
everywhere
for instance this is a figure from a
from a genomics uh paper
and
you know they analyze data that are
you know
genomic sequences for for i don't know a
large population in south america and so
you can think that each column this is a
representation of this data and each
column in this
figure is one of my zero one vectors
right and you know a very simple uh task
that one can ask here is estimate the
the you know mean genomic signature in
this population now as this figure shows
it's not always the case that you know
the this population is homogeneous in
this case they distinguish various sub
sub population depending on the country
of the origin of of these patients
and
and uh therefore an interesting model
for data of this type is a model in
which you have multiple sub-populations
okay so okay we have theoreticians so
let's make up a model for this you have
perhaps two subpopulations just to to
have the simplest possible case
and so you have a matrix that is perhaps
n by d
and the set of samples is partitioned in
two subsets
within the first subset the expectation
of each column is a certain vector p1
and within the second subset is another
vector p2
okay and uh
and uh okay our goal is to estimate p1
and p2 of course if we know the sub
population this is very similar to the
task that we were trying to solve before
but
we like uh challenges so let's say that
we don't know the sub-population
and so the columns of these metrics are
not ordered and therefore
you know figuring out who is who is is
much more difficult
and
of course also the row are not ordered
the way i ordered the row in my previous
pictures was very special to make things
easy to see but now
things are very hard to see so now we
have the same data as before
and the same distribution except
that rows and columns are
randomly scrambled
and this is not a purely made up example
you might think for instance that
you know
a certain you know genomic pattern
depends on sub-population that you're
not aware of right
that are latent and so you cannot
identify with the country of origin
this is actually a significant
undertaking in genomics
all right so you can ask two statistical
questions here
one statistical question is you know
estimate p1 and p2 and of course the
difficult part of it is estimating the
difference between the two vector
because the average you can average all
and the other is estimate who is who in
the two subpopulation you can think that
yeah so
no in each of them so so if you know one
part of the puzzle of course solving the
whole puzzle
if solving the other part is easy but
let's say that we don't know any so we
don't know s1 and s2 and we don't know
p1 and p2 and we want to do
let's say one or the other or both of
them
so the question is
how hard is it and and can we do it how
accurately we can estimate this
difference
okay let me focus just let's say that
that our goal to to to make things
concrete is that to estimate this
difference
and uh
and okay so the the we learned this you
know how to you know derive this
information here in the way inbound
actually we derived a couple of them
and uh
and actually let me let me take a
shortcut and you know tell you something
very obvious
if you
say yes shafi said
let's say that for instance we know the
set c
s1 and s2
then of course the problem reduces to
the previous one basically because you
can average within s1 and average with
respect to s2
and therefore the accuracy we can within
which i can estimate the difference
is lower bounded as before it's at least
square root of d overall
okay on the other hand you understand
that if if the signal is too small you
will not be able to
identify s1 and s2 and so the problem
can become
significantly more difficult
okay so and i think that
the the
the answer is that
for any estimator theta you can estimate
theta with accuracy at least square root
of n over d times the max of
one and one over theta
one over norm of theta
and we can achieve this by a spectral
method
okay the form of this result is not that
important
right so
and you want to estimate to want to
figure out whether they are exactly
right or not
yeah that or or they are close that
i would think okay i never thought about
this problem as to confess
but my blind guess would be that is not
difficult right because
you know
you can compute the distribution of some
statistics assuming that s1 is correct
and then check that
you know what you see satisfies that
distribution right
now the question is okay
so if the the other person is
adversarial and figures out this one is
too in the in the worst possible case to
confuse me can i do it
yeah i mean this that problem is is not
of course it's not uh
harder than this problem right because i
can always estimate it you know if i can
estimate this 1 is 2 then i can compare
with what this person gives me
and and
with so you give me s1 s2 to full
you are giving me p1 and p2
okay but uh but uh i think that the
question is uh
is similar right because i can you know
if you give me the difference i can
project all the data around this
difference right
and
you know if if you give me the
difference in in the right way the data
along that direction satisfied
will be two very concentrated gaussian
speed basically right now the question
is can you take
a direction that is at so if you take an
arbitrary other direction you should
shouldn't be able to to fool me i mean
in direction without looking at the data
if you take me p1 and p2 looking at the
data and trying me to fool me in an
adversarial way still
that shouldn't be harder that
the task that i'm trying to achieve
because i'm always
uh yeah i can always forget what you
told me try to estimate p1 or p1 and p2
and then
does that make sense
by the way that's a good thing because
there is many experts in the room and
it's good to have
okay so
okay so so the summary for from this
more complicated example is the
following
uh
if i want to estimate titanon trivially
when the norm of theta is of order one
then i need at least
n over these samples in this example
okay so it's not easier or not harder
than the problem in which you don't know
s1 and s2 if the signal is sufficiently
large
okay so so everything that i discussed
so far was in in a sense very nice and
and very easy
in what sense it was nice and easy
well you know we proved that in many
cases that
no estimator can do so perhaps i should
say something about this this case this
problem
i said this this this error is achieved
by spectral method what is the spectral
method is take this matrix
that is the you know 0 1 metrics that i
i
draw with colors before
and then you can compute the eigenvalue
decomposition of that matrix there and
and compute the top two eigenvectors
okay so
can compute sum over i
one two perhaps d and then
uh lambda i
ui bi transpose and then the second
eigenvector
u2
should be an estimate for theta hat
if the if the two populations are
balanced
or or you can or in other ways that you
take x and you subtract you first
estimate the mean the mean
p and then you subtract p times one
transpose
so you subtract the overall average and
then you compute the top low right
eigenvector of this
subtracted matrix
and this this again should be an
estimate for theta hat
so this you define to be theta hat
and the claim is that this tita hat if
if the signal is strong enough aligns
well with theta
okay so
so
this method is all the algorithm that i
described so far were very very simple
in the sense they were you know either
take the average of the data or the most
complicated algorithm that they
described was uh
just do the singular value the
composition of the data matrix
and you know within a constant all of
this algorithm achieve
the you know what we we claimed our
information theory bottlenecks
and
so everything was very nice so far
uh but turns out that you know the set
of examples set of problems in which
everything is very nice is
somehow a very small subset of all
possible problems that we are interested
in and this is a very easy way to
to you know land in a in a territory
that is is much more challenging
as as before so this is the exactly the
same example
as before
except we don't know
i mean except that p1 and p2 don't
differ in
all of the the entries
but we know that only differing
k of out of the d entries okay that here
here i drew them as the first k
so all of the other
entries are junk and and the other are
different okay and uh you know if you
think back of our genomic example this
is not such a you know far-fetched
hypothesis because you might imagine of
two population that different you know a
very small subset of genes
and they are
completely identical otherwise
okay and as before let's say
we
we don't know which entries differ we
don't know the two subpopulation and we
don't have any ordering of the rules of
this matrix so now we have a
zero one matrix and we want to again for
instance estimate the difference of p1
and p2
so so mathematically what does this mean
it means that
instead of a vector theta as before that
is you know for instance of norm
one
we have a vector theta that is
guaranteed to have only
uh k non-zero entries
okay
or or you know the notation for these is
normally that the zeroth norm of theta
is at most k
okay so if i think about it this should
help because
okay it's more information about theta
if
you know i know that it has a specific
structure so information theoretically
there should be much less details that
that are possible
okay and so we can go
over the same information theoretical
argument to understand how much this
should help and okay a piece of notation
that is
convenient here is a concept that we
already used a few times
that is uh what's called the packing
number
that is given a subset of possible
vector theta
the maximum number of delta separated
vectors in this set
delta separator means that the distance
between any two of them is at least
delta
okay so what we did before is is somehow
compute packing numbers of balls right
of euclidean balls
the packing number of the ball of radius
one
i claim that is a constant over delta
to the d
and this by you know again what i
described before as a volume argument
right is just i divide the ball i
in little balls of radius delta
and how many i can pack
i can back packet most you know the
ratio of the two volumes that is the
ratio of constant to the d over delta to
the d
the important thing here is that this
number depends exponentially on d and
this drives all the complexity uh sample
complexity result that i
i described
now if i repeat the same calculation for
the set of vectors that have sparsity at
most k
what do i get
well
i i can choose the k
the k entries that are non-zero and
there are these two choose k ways of
doing that
and then you know once i choose which
one non-zero i can
choose a vector of unit norm there and
how many ways there are of doing this
well we did it before it's constant over
delta to the k because this leaves in k
dimensions
so the the the binomial is at
at most d to the k
uh and therefore if i write in
exponential form you know for delta
constant the first term
dominates
and so this will be e to the k log d
e to the
constant times k to look d
so what was exponential in the dimension
before is exponential in k l of d now
okay this suggests what suggests that
perhaps the complexity of such a
estimation problem with k-sparse vectors
is not controlled by the dimension
but by some kind of effective dimension
that perhaps in this case is something
like k log d right so this is just the
back of the envelope calculation is it's
not the proof of anything
but in fact it turns out to be to be
true
and you know you can okay one should
state things properly but
i'm just uh
giving the the idea of the theorem you
can estimate in this model theta where i
wrote with error that is of order square
root of k log d over
and
no no metal can be substantially better
okay so this is good news in a sense our
simple backup the envelope calculation
worked
unfortunately there is bad news is that
the way you prove this theorem is not as
before by coming up with a very nice
simple algorithm
but whether
this theorem or better theorems in this
problem are proved is basically but by
doing exhaustive search i mean the
positive result of the theorem is
exhaustive search overall subset of size
k
and this of course requires time of
order t d to the k
that unless k is very you know is over
there one is is non-polynomial
okay so this is the proof of the theorem
you might wonder whether
we know how to do better
and
and the answer is no and this is uh even
worse news this this problem is known as
sparse principal component analysis and
was
you know introduced perhaps 15 years ago
i don't remember precisely but but since
then many people have thought about it
and all polynomial time algorithms
uh
that
succeed with you know
high probability require that the sample
size is at least k square here just
reducing myself for simplicity to the
case in which
you know this matrix is approximately
square
okay so so now i i spent most of my
presentation or
you know part of my presentation
uh you know describing uh all that
motivates you know this program and
this this gap between what you know
can be achieved information
theoretically and what we know how to
achieve in polynomial time
is what at least in this program and
this community we find exciting
okay so
what i want to to try to convey here is
you know in the next you know few
minutes is that this is not
an isolated example but is actually
a prototype of of many other examples so
i call it a menagerie because i like the
name menagerie which means a strange or
diverse collection of people or things
according to the dictionary but in
reality
uh this phenomenon of information
computation gap is far from being exotic
is the kind of things that once you know
about it you you see everywhere
and some of us end up being obsessed by
it
uh
the simplest
or the simplest the the most useful
problem in statistics is regression
right so regression is problem which you
have
covariates excise that are d dimensional
and responses y i
and then you want to uh you know perhaps
they are related by a linear model so y
i r theta x i plus noise
you have n samples from these linear
models
model and and you want to estimate theta
okay
think for instance of if you want to go
back to genomics you want to regress
some phenotype for instance height
or on the genotype
okay and uh okay if you if theta is in a
bowl this is essentially
achieved by some simple linear method
like you know a variant of least squares
but if theta is some
additional constraints as
for example sparsity
on top of the l2 l2 constraint then very
easily uh this displays an information
computation gap
so information computation gap i refer
you i mean a gap between what we know
how to achieve information theoretically
and what we know how to achieve
in polynomial time
next example is clustering in high
dimension
say that we have a you know convex
combination a combination of of n k
gaussian distribution the simplest
possible example all isotropic
or all with common covariance
at centers detail
and i want to estimate the sample the
the center's detail so this is a picture
in which i have how many one two
three four
five gaussians
and
let's say that we are looking at it in
high dimension so the number of samples
is
is uh proportional to the dimension
okay
so our data matrix is basically uh
rectangular with order one aspect ratio
and i want to estimate the k centers
if k becomes you know some
small number bigger than four
then you know
we observe gaps between what we achieve
uh by polynomial time algorithms for
instance by spectral methods and
what can be done information
theoretically
time source this is something that has
become
increasingly popular in in data science
everybody now knows that you have if you
have a matrix you could do the singular
value decomposition and so people that
know more linear algebra
look at the data time source okay this
is an example from a paper on
epigenomics that i actually don't know
what it is
but you know they have a data set with
uh cell types and assays and
and patients
and so it's a three-dimensional data
block
and uh and what they want to try we want
to you know infer some low dimensional
latent structure on it
the simplest possible latent structure
is this one in which you assume that the
tensor is around one tensor plus noise
of course this model can be easily
easily generalized
but say that we are this type of tensors
and and now you want to estimate theta
one theta two
and theta three
that are three vectors while in the
metrics case you can do it nearly
optimally as i said before by spectral
method in the tensor case there are uh
you know
large gaps between what we can do uh in
theory and what you can do in practice
and in fact it turns out that basically
one of the best method that we have is
to flatten the tensor so to forget that
it is a tensor altogether that is
somehow at odds with what
practitioners
for instance in this paper are doing
and finally optimization and and this
this list could go on and on but even
you know
simple to state optimization problem
with the random data of large
information computation gaps here i
brought two of my
uh simple
favorite optimization problems that are
spinglass models
the first one is optimize a
a
quadratic function of the hub over the
hypercube and the second one is
optimize a third order polynomial over
the hyper cube
and okay these of course problems that
are hard in the worst case
but uh say you know motivated by what we
were talking about say that the data
random and the simplest possible model
is that all of these coefficients are
iad
and now something very interesting
happens is that for this problem we have
a one minus epsilon approximation for
any epsilon
while this problem uh appears to be you
know difficult to or hard to approximate
within
one minus epsilon factor
okay so so
basically has gone
as soon as we move
you know to problems that have a minimum
of you know non-trivial structure
information competition gap arise very
naturally
so the last few minutes or five minutes
of this talk i want to discuss
what people in this area uh
are doing or people in this program are
doing
so what are they are trying to do is is
you know basically come up with evidence
that in fact this information
computation gap exist and to incite
with insight as to when do they arise
and why what are optimal algorithms
and what are things that people do to do
this
well
one standard reflex for for for
a computer science point of view is
is uh to do reduction and this is you
know a figure
from a recent paper on the topic that
shows how you know
uh you know to construct a certain
number of of reductions about between
problems of of
of uh you know statistical estimation
problem for instance the problem that i
i described before the the one with two
sub-population that differ only and a
small number of rows is is this one in
this in this network of reduction
now you know okay since this is a cart
lectures i cannot i cannot you know
not notice you know the resemblance that
is almost a citation between this figure
and that figure that is from the 1972 so
we can ask perhaps the authors of that
paper is
that was deliberate
okay of course you know doing reductions
in this setting is is more you know it's
trickier than
you know classical
reductions
because probabilities involved
so what does a reduction means here
well first of all what is a problem
you know in essence a problem is is the
following you have a space of instances
okay and here i should have written
this you have a space of instances and
each instance is is a sample like a
matrix
and a you know
an integer 0 1 and then
okay these are each each each
instance is for instance a matrix and
then you have
two distribution over instances p0 and
p1
and this for each of two problems
and so you
think that you reduce problem one to
problem two
that is establishing that one is easier
than two means to you know construct a
polytime
uh map fee from the space of instances
of problem 1 to space of
instances of problem 2
such that
okay i have a typo here
the following happens
when applied the map
to instances of the first problem the
probability of okay so i i brought it
the other way
this is two and this is one
apologies
okay so when i map uh
the the apply the map to instances of
the first problem uh
and then uh i compute the oh this is
correct like this
this is v x one and one
uh
yeah actually was correct as it was i
think okay so if i apply the map to
problems from
an instance from problem one here
and i compute the probability that some
event happens
this is the same as the probability that
the same event happens
when i don't apply the map but i draw x
from from problem two so i had only one
type here
okay so this is a reduction and of
course the challenge here is that you
know we know how to construct reduction
but it's very difficult to construct
reduction that preserve probabilities
the second type of things type of
evidence for hardness uh is very
different from classical thinking and
comes from the from analyzing the
geometry of the space of solution
and this is an insight that originally
came from physics
and
the what was found in physics is the
four often problems that are hard on
average
have the following
uh
phenomenon happening
the space of near optimal solutions
splits into well-separated cluster
and the first example in which this was
at least theoristically shown was random
case satisfiability if you drive random
case satisfaction close to the threshold
the the you know set of solutions split
into clusters
of solutions where any two clusters are
separated by distance of order t
okay so this subsequently was proved
and
uh you know recently people were able to
show that this clustering of of solution
rules out certain classes of algorithms
so what is the rough idea for why why
this happens why clustering makes
solution
solving this problem harder
well i want to describe it very high
level what happens is that most
algorithms are smooth functions of the
input depend
nicely on the input if you change a few
entries of the input the output doesn't
change too much
is for instance lip sheets in the input
now in many of this problem the input is
random and there's basically independent
entries think for instance of random
satisfiability each of the entries is a
clause of my random satisfaction
a problem as in is independent or in my
you know sparse principle component
analysis problem each each entry was
independent or in my optimization of of
cubic polynomial each coefficient of the
cubic polynomial was an independent
random variable
right and now we know that it's basic
principle of modern probabilities that
smooth function of independent random
variable concentrates so
the space of outcomes of this algorithm
should concentrate and so it shouldn't
have this multi-modal structure that we
see in the
in the space of solutions okay so the
fact that you cannot reproduce this
multimeter model structure with the
with the outcome or with the output of a
smooth algorithm is
what makes it uh possible to prove that
this smooth algorithms
fail when the
the when the
when the solution space exhibit
clustering of course you need
a bit more because
you know okay you need a bit more but
this is the the
one basic intuition of of the argument
and finally another very rich uh you
know direction is
okay
you know once was reduction one was
reduction the second one was was
geometry of the space of solution and
then there is more direct analysis of
classes of algorithms
and and here i've you know described
a few classes of such algorithms
uh from you know simplest algorithms for
which is is easier to prove a negative
result to more complex algorithm the
simplest algorithms are probably
what i would call first order methods
this if you think again to our running
example in which the data was a data
matrix access the data matrix by matrix
vector multiplication
so you you start with a vector and then
you multiply that vector by x and then
you do some other operation on the
vectors
a broader class of algorithms is what
people call
low degree polynomials these compute
polynomial functions of the input that
are
polynomials of low degree this can be of
course computed efficiently and include
most of the algorithm of the first type
as special cases
and finally you know convex relaxation
methods are are
quite popular in practice
and
you know the connection between convex
optimization and estimation is
you know you start with an estimation
problem then you formulate it as a
combinatorial optimization problem and
then you lift the combinatorial
optimization problem to a convex
optimization problem
this has been extremely successful uh
within within
you know high dimensional statistics
uh think of compressed sensing or phase
retrieval or metrics completion but now
we understand well that are you know
limitation that is as severe for these
type of approaches as
for others
okay so as as the last piece of of
information you know the you know part
of the audience might be completely
disappointed because this whole talk is
about bad news basically is about the
fact that
we wish to achieve certain accuracy but
we cannot
uh
it turns out that there is a
surprisingly common phenomenon that i
think we don't understand really is that
in many of this problem
the optimal statistical accuracy that
can be achieved by polynomial time
algorithm is actually achieved
by very simple polynomial time algorithm
so there is a kind of collapse of the
so if you don't know if you are not a
good algorithm designer in many cases
you still can get away uh
with with you know can construct good
algorithms
and in particular a lot of milia mileage
is is obtained by
you know special spectral methods in
which you typically start with an
editometric sex a data set x and then
construct a certain matrix a
and then a set of vector
and then you compute the eigenvector or
the singular vectors of these metrics
and these give you an estimate of the
underlying parameters
and
what i called before generalized first
order methods and among these
approximate message passing that
basically construct similarly a matrix
and then
access these metrics via a small number
of matrix vector multiplications
okay of course there are exceptions to
this idea that
very simple algorithms are optimal but
you know
for many interesting problem that is the
case
so this is
an example of this type that is
similar
to the one
that i described before is a symmetric
matrix
plus noise so you observe a symmetric
rank 1 matrix x 0 x 0 transpose where x
0 is
sparse
so this is r n and epsilon n sparse
and i think this figure was done with
epsilon
0.0025 some constant number
in this case we we we can compute
precisely with what is the optimal
accuracy that can be achieved by
any
information theoretically
can be achieved information
theoretically actually is this black
with that this
dark blue line
actually start the dark blue line is
this dark blue line it has a inter so
this is a function of this snr parameter
lambda
it has a jump a phase transition at a
certain
point that we know perfectly
and you know continues to one
and
we can characterize also precisely what
is the conjecture algolith algorithmic
threshold and there is a gap between the
two
and here the the data points are are
you know simulations from a very simple
algorithm that achieves the the
optimal performance among polynomial
time methods
okay so just i want to do it you know
give a word of conclusion from a
statistician point of view since i sit
in a statistics department
and what is the interaction between
statistics and computation
and
okay of course there is a classical age
here represented by by fischer famous
uh papers on the on the
mathematical foundations of theoretical
statistics in which
statistics was mainly a
manual
work
and then sometime in the 70s computer
had you know a disruptive impact and the
arrays are presented by
uh
the 72 paper by brad efron on the
bootstrap
and you know computers made possible
things that were not
even
dreamed up before and made some of the
things that people worked on before
obsolete but there wasn't a
real
impact of what are the limitations of of
uh computers or or
of
uh algorithms and i think recently we
started
realizing these computational
limitations and appreciating them and
you know trying to map them out
okay i omitted from my my you know
caller references because i should give
too much but
if anybody wants to read stuff about
this i i have a small list of references
that are
some of my
favorite papers and
i think that's all
questions
uh
finding you know these essays and
verifying
of
or or you know you're given a p1
there's a claim of p1p2 and now you want
to verify that that's correct so i'm
interested in this question of verifying
for
for machine learning in general but in
particular for these type of statistics
is
could you imagine that there's different
barriers different gaps between
computational and
information theory for the
problem of verifying so but in your
model that the person that gives me you
know is an adversary it's another but
it's an adversary that sees the data or
doesn't see that he sees the data he
does the consultation he comes up with a
claim and then the question is how
costly it is to verify
given that it's hard enough to compute
this maybe it's not an interesting
question it's a much more interesting
question when
if there is a you know so your question
is whether there is a separation between
the verification problem and the
estimation problem in which the
verification problem is easier than the
estimation
i would think yeah i mean it should be
easier i mean
but uh
i mean of course if the adversary is not
not powerful competition is easier the
conversation sees the data
[Music]
let's say i mean what what the adversary
would do with is try to so okay let's
take
i don't know what it is
so all of these problems are this time
right so
so there is despair right and uh
so the the question is whether you can
come up with another theta prime that is
very different from theta and such that
the joint distribution
is uh of this so the adversary would
come from something that is different
from theta and such that the joint
distribution of of theta prime x is
you know indistinguishable from theta x
by a bounded computation
okay so the story being that there's
someone who's done the work and they
want to for you and they know that they
like a genetic
example they claim that they've
discovered the following and you want to
verify that their discovery is correct
with less
resources
right
i don't know
foreign
yeah and it's not super obvious right
because yes the i could hand you the
planted partition but what you would
have to show
for this to be a and then you can what
do you check if i check some statistics
locally of that partition or something
you have to show that in a null model
graph where there's no partition that
the adversary can't look at the graph
and hook up some partitions there
because of weird fluctuations in their
enemies
that would cause the would match the
statistics you know that are easy to use
yeah i think i remember that that was
the problem posed by prasad and we
worked on that problem and i think that
we solved it in the case in which
you know rank one plus noise problem we
we had a solution but now i don't
remember anymore what was that
i mean where the sketch of proof
for that problem
uh
is the information so the theorem is
supposed to be the dna
sorry i i think the theorem is meant to
be what guy said that the that the np
thing for most of these coincides with
the information theory theoretic
transition so it gets much easier it
gets as easy as it could possibly be
yeah the verifier is polynomial time the
verifier just computes some some easy
statistics of the joint distribution of
the planted
uh you know cut cut or spike or whatever
and the noise or in the instance
but i think proving proving this is
pretty hard
i think that
okay i remember this working group and i
think that
we solved i mean we we worked on it for
for exactly the last problem that has
described
okay and i think that the idea was you
you know some you know the adversary
come up with this
and then our idea was you run something
like
amp
starting an iterative algorithm starting
with this initialization and then
you you check whether you converge to
something that has the same the right
property of of a fixed point so
we computed the the top free energy or
something like that and we checked that
so to make sure that that that won't
happen no matter what your starting
point is for a
for a no model thing
the point is that there is
i think it's symmetry
yeah so i don't don't remember whether
yeah
i mean there is much more randomness in
the in the noise matrix that possible
choices of the vector but yeah i don't
remember
the answer but let me ask you back uh
question shafi uh
uh
i mean suppose that uh i know to solve
it in some simple modernists right
uh
really
you know what is the motivation so
motivation is as i said if you're
thinking about delegating these problems
out you've got very large data says very
large
um like the genetic example make
sequences you don't have the power to do
the computation somebody has done it for
you it claims now
that um
these are the expectations or whatever
it is that you're looking for these are
the good estimates of p hat or
um and how do you verify it because it
might have been maybe they're not
telling you something to the accuracy
today
claim
yeah
um to me it's a natural
especially in this world where there's a
few eight entities that have the
computing power and the
ability to
to do this type of statistics on large
scale but the customer or whoever's
using it might not have that power
okay
yeah
you